hi guys so I just had a great idea
basically sometimes have youtubers they
record videos even if they don't want to
you can clearly tell if somebody isn't
in the mood for making a YouTube video
yeah he does it anyway because youtube
money and living off of youtube and all
that so yeah sometimes you have some
mood swings and you don't want to record
youtube videos and I have that as well
obviously and I don't record all the
time he'll sometimes those is like I I
don't record videos for two weeks simply
because I don't feel like it and if I'm
in the mood for it I just record so many
videos but I just had an idea and this
might actually work because what i just
did before i was making this video or at
least doing this commentary is i was
wasting time in a great way I was
watching all the intros of all the shows
that I watched them I in my childhood
and watching basically awesome stuff so
now I'm in a great mood so I don't know
if that would actually work for anyone
if that's actually a good idea but I
guess it's cool but anyway about the
city basically what i was playing what i
was planning for this episode is people
have been talking about a river and i
was like I definitely do want a river
somewhere because first of all of course
a river looks great that's really
awesome but it's also something that you
can place the camera on you can take
nice pictures and movies from a river
and as cliche as it may be a Riverside
is always beautiful to have in your city
and of course there's one more aspect of
that it's the fact that you generally
don't have cities when when there's not
a river nearby or the sea or something
like that because apparently you can't
trade and more important things that
cities need to do because their cities
so yeah whatever floats their boat so no
pun intended but so yeah i figured i
would have a river so here we go a nice
little river and a bridge now of course
that does need a little Boulevard if you
will so of course I'm kind of going to
build that but it's not going to be all
that special it's just going to be a
normal Road except it's going to have an
extra wide sidewalk with planters and
fancy looking lamp posts so that
everybody is going to be certain that
this is a Boulevard and this is like the
little pair
of this area except it's not really
going to be like Paris because you can't
you can't obviously do that though it
would be pretty amazing because at this
point I have pretty much given up on the
idea of building a realistic city I
never really wanted to do that in the
first place but the more I build on this
city the more I give up on that entire
idea for multiple reasons but basically
the fact that I want to create a city
that looks nice and that i like and the
problem is that i don't like most cities
in real life and especially I wouldn't
like building them in roller coaster
tycoon 3 because considering the size of
the downtown and the buildings and the
way or everything looks this would be in
the middle of a city with at least sixty
thousand inhabitants and you can't make
a city like that in roller coaster
tycoon 3 as in size wise there's no way
you can really do that and you're going
to have to fill the entire area with sub
urban areas with all kinds of houses
that look exactly the same and you don't
want to do that in roller coaster tycoon
3 at least I don't want to there's no
space for that and it's very boring
nobody would want to watch that and it's
not really interesting to look at and
it's probably a waste of time anyway
because nobody cares about those areas
right people just live in them and
there's nothing else really so yeah I'm
just going for a utopian style city if
you will but then again I'm still afraid
to say that because of course it's not
going to be the best city ever and of
course it's gonna have a couple of ugly
buildings in it because I'm just winging
it here just building random buildings
and hoping that everything will work out
but really there's no planning info so
some buildings will kind of look not as
good in the end though that's again
that's not really a problem because
every city of course has some ugly
buildings in it but me being a
profession is I don't want that and
every building in my city needs to be
perfect but I did the side that if I
build a building that I don't really
like I'm just going to move on and not
remove it because otherwise I turn out
like that one person like which I I know
people in the ICT three community who do
this and learn let me give you one piece
of good advice never ever ever do that
never be that perfectionist
who removes his things when he doesn't
really like it because what you get then
is you build things that maybe others
really like actually but then you feel
like it's not perfect and you remove the
entire thing I know somebody I'm not
going to drop names because that's not
really nice but like well actually I
know more persons actually there's one
person who's worked on a coaster for
three years and many people know that
it'sit's ashbridge of course there was
this wooden coaster and ICT lounge and
somebody worked on that thing for three
years and it was not it was not like
it's the biggest thing ever but people
made huge amusement park in a shorter
amount of time simply because muffins or
from ashbridge he just felt like it
wasn't perfect every time and it's time
to remove things and redo them and that
went on for three years when he
eventually decided that he would make a
POV and I think he's not even that happy
with it even though he should be because
ashbridge is one of the best what wooden
roller coasters in while ago psycho
through ever hands down it's amazing but
what what I sometimes see and like well
sometimes see some people doing is they
build things and then when I like and I
don't really like this they remove
something and they don't just remove a
small portion of something but they
remove the entire building and that's
that's just going to be a waste of time
because for one you don't know for
certain that the building that you're
going to replace it with is actually
something that you you're gonna like
sometimes if you remove a building and
feel like okay I'm going to build
something else the the thing that you
built in place of the old one it
actually looks worse than your one so
there you're not just back to square one
but it's actually worse than what you
started with really what I I kind of
feel like is the best thing to do is
just come to terms with the building
that you built even if you don't like it
and just move on like how even some
other people might just like it because
that's what I've seen with some people
that I kind I've gone to known for a
long time they would send me things and
be like well I don't like this thing I'm
gonna remove it and I'd be like no don't
because I like it late I know that you
usually want to have make projects that
you like and not anybody else but
again I feel like my buildings would be
pretty safe if I didn't even like it
that much but others do I would be
pretty happy with it I would just keep
it there for the others to look at or
something like that I don't really know
I just feel like it's a waste of effort
and well creativity in a sense if you
remove buildings that you've built
simply because they're not perfect so
yeah that was my huge talk about that
and right now I'm building this little
building which I designed to be well I
didn't design this building to be
anything really i just started out with
a general shape I was like now I'm just
gonna try this and I didn't really like
the shape of it but now that I built it
I felt like it kind of looks like a
church so I put that cross on top of it
but the cross just kind of looked ugly
so decided to remove that thing in the
end and just keep it like I don't know
some kind of community buildings I don't
know if you have those things in America
but at least over here in the
Netherlands every neighborhood has their
own little community building where they
do community things but that might just
be socialism in the Netherlands but yeah
that's basically that so I felt like
might as well make one of those things
really you can but you can pretty much
say anything about this building I don't
think that the shape and the size of
this building really dictates what what
it is so I do need to watch out that I
don't make too many like buildings for
the community in the city as a whole
because the bill I've been building way
too many shops and stuff like this and
schools I don't even know one some
things are supposed to be when you
compare it to how many houses are
actually built and how many actual
office buildings have actually built so
I'm definitely going to make a sub urban
area somewhere and of course I'm going
to add a couple more towers to the
downtown area definitely not too many
though and not very high towers simply
because also something that I want to
say is where you're building a downtown
and nobody is probably going to do this
but when you build a huge coin scraper
it's going to wash the other things so
like there's a city in the Netherlands
and why everybody knows why should I
even say those it's Rotterdam and
everybody
is it for its amazing skyline or
something I don't like it at all it's
it's freaking ugly but whatever and the
highest building is 160 meters and the
thin people proposing to build a 300
meter high tower in the middle of
Rotterdam but that simply wouldn't work
simply because it would dwarf the other
buildings the skyline looks somewhat
impressive right now because all of the
buildings in the entire area are as flat
as a pancake so really any somewhat high
skyscraper is going to stand out and
create a nice skyline but as soon as you
place a 300-meter hi Scott skyscraper in
the middle of that it's kind of going to
dwarf it kind of in a similar way to
what the shard does in London except
this shot is not even that high can when
compared to the other buildings in
London so doesn't it isn't really that
bad though honestly if you ask me London
skyline is not all that good either when
we're on the topic of skylines I think
the skyline front foot is probably the
best one in Europe and also Warsaw is
really good and Moscow it's really good
Paris is pretty decent loneliness pretty
decent too and that's about it when it
comes to skylines I think skylines
aren't really a Europe thing I think the
best car lines in the world are in Asia
definitely Tokyo is really awesome and
Singapore and Hong Kong of course a
ridiculously good and Dubai would be
another great example of what could have
been as kind a great skyline but what
was kind of ruined by the enormous tower
in the middle of it but anyway thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you
all in the next episode so bye